Publish a new app for every developer
Or post a new version of the app
It’s an exciting time
This is a very crucial moment
Pay attention to all the details
Ensure that users are very satisfied with your app
To make this process easier
We are promoting a new way to publish apps
Google Developer Console
First create a new app list
Click to create the app
You can get the new management release page in the left navigation bar.
Then you go to this page
On this page you can see the steps to publish your app.
Product testing and alpha trajectory
Of course, we recommend testing all the apps.
This way you can test new features better before publishing.
If this is the first time you posted the page is blank
You need to choose a path to publish
For example, choose a management product
Then the new product is released
Click Upload APK and then pop up as usual
Then select the file you want to upload.
After uploading the APK
There will be additional items in the APK
The name of the post is the name of the APK you uploaded.
After the app is updated
Don't forget to fill out the new features posted.
You have to give it to your app list.
All supported languages
Localization
The best thing about managing the release process is
No matter when you can save the draft release data
Then go get the rest of the list
After a while, you will finish the data you just saved.
If you want to go back to your saved state
Click Manage to publish the management product and click Continue.
Once it can be released
You click to check
Then you will see a summary
If no validation error occurs
Click OK to go online and you can post your app.
Then you will return to the release page.
If you want to update an existing app process, it will be a bit different.
Because the selection method clicks on the new version
Will create a new draft as before
But this draft is based on the previous release
Previously released APK
All will enter the disabled APK list
Of course, if you want, you can choose to keep
Click the hold button
You can keep the old APK
Because maybe the old APK is useful for previous API versions.
At this stage, how many APKs do you want to add?
Every time you upload you will see a basic popup page
There is information about the APK inside.
Here you can attach extension files
After finishing the new APK as before
You can edit the version name and new features
After all the information is filled out
Can check
If you want to track the product
You can summarize the page
Directly change the online ratio
We recommend running your app step by step.
I have done this recently.
Especially important app version
So you can do it all before your app is uploaded.
Found a problem to solve the problem
Can avoid negative reviews and low scores
In the Google Developer Help Center
You can learn more about the content of the stage.
As long as you are ready, you can adjust the on-line ratio
Click update to go online
Then change the value
If you don't know what percentage to choose
We will have suggestions
If you have questions about the ongoing phase
It’s very easy to stop it now.
Click the Stop online button and confirm
pay attention
Stop phase online
New users can't download new versions.
But users who have made the wrong update will still have the wrong version.
So please remind me as soon as possible
Fix it and create another version later
Upload release
Just stop the wrong version.
Of course, if you have not created a new version, you can fix it.
Maybe you fixed it on your own server.
You can choose to continue online at any time.
Another feature we released
Can help you better control the release of new products.
Workpiece library
Includes APK extension file
And other app files
If you go to the managed release of the artifact library
You can see the update in the app artifact.
You can see all the uploaded files related to the app you posted.
With this new management release feature
Managing your app now can be smoother
More transparent and easier to track
It allows you to manage your app more confidently